[Music]
cloud gel editor makes it easy for you
to write code directly in your web
browser and deploy it to the cloud
powered by the eclipse the ide platform
cloud shell editor provides a rich
experience that makes it easy for you to
debug your applications before deploying
to the cloud
in this video we'll walk through an
example of how to run and debug
a local deployment of a cloud run
service cloudron makes it easy to deploy
highly scalable containerized
applications on a fully managed
serverless platform
but before you deploy to cloud run you
may want to run your app locally to
simplify the debugging process
first visit ide.cloud.google.com to
launch the cloud shell editor
on the status bar at the bottom of your
screen click cloud code
from the cloud code menu click new
application and then select the cloud
run application
for the type of sample app we want to
create
after that we'll get a list of cloud run
templates to choose from
let's go with the node.js option next
select a folder in your cloud shell
environment to save your application to
and give it a name
if that looks good click create new
application cloud shell editor clones
the files for your sample application
from github into a new workspace
you can see the list of files in the
explorer panel located on the left side
of the screen
now let's go ahead and run this
application locally
from the cloud code menu click run on
cloud run emulator
in the run debug on cloud run emulator
dialog you can choose your builder and
adjust build and service settings
we'll leave everything as your default
values for now after defining your
preferred settings click
run right now cloud code is spinning up
an environment that emulates cloudrun's
production environment
you can monitor the progress of your
application in the output window
you may need to click authorize to
authorize cloud shell to make google
cloud platform api calls
once your app is built you can launch it
by hovering over the url link displayed
in the output panel and clicking open
web preview
congratulations if you see this page
that means you successfully run your
cloud run app locally
once your service is running there are
some other options you can access from
the cloud code status bar
you can open deployment logs open this
service url
or turn watch mode on or off with watch
mode
cloud code continually watches the file
system for changes to your files
if changes are detected it will redeploy
your application so that your edits are
reflected in near real time
once you're done you can click the stop
button to stop running your service
now that you've learned how to develop
locally with cloud run let's take a look
at how you can debug a cloud run
application
click the explorer icon in the upper
left to display all the code files
let's double click on index.js to open
it
let's go ahead and add some code to the
app's root directory we'll create two
variables and give them initial values
a third variable will be set to equal
the sum of the first two variables
finally we'll increment the first
variable
to add a breakpoint just click in the
editor margin of the file you're
debugging
once it's added the breakpoint will
appear as a red circle
we'll go ahead and add five breakpoints
starting with our first line of extra
code
now let's go ahead and run our service
locally with the debugger session
attached
from the cloud code menu click debug on
cloud run emulator
next press enter to confirm that the
application you like to debug can be
found in the listed directory
once you see the orange bar at the
bottom you are now in debug mode
launch the app by hovering over the url
link displayed in the output panel
and clicking open web preview now go
back to the cloud shell editor window
you'll see that the application has
pause at the first break point which is
now a red dot outlined in yellow
in the debug sidebar you can manage the
debugging session with the debugging
action icons
continue step over step into
step out restart and stop
the debug sidebar also includes sections
for you to view information about the
call stack
variable values and breakpoints
if we open up the local variables
section we see that our three variables
start out as undefined
let's go ahead and click the continue
icon this advances us to the next
breakpoint
we see in the variables section that the
value of foo has changed to five
if we keep clicking continue the values
of the other variables change as well
we can also hover over the variables in
the code to see what their updated
values are
in this case the foo variable now equals
6 because it was incremented
once we get to the last breakpoint we
can click continue to run through the
rest of the program
since there aren't any errors this
results in a functional web page
once you're done you can click the stop
button to stop your debugging session
and there you have it cloud channel
editor provides a full ide experience
that makes it easy for you to develop
and debug all kinds of applications
right from your web browser
to get started with cloud shell editor
visit ide.cloud.google.com
make sure to subscribe to the channel
and stay tuned for more cloud shell
editor videos